More evidence that having a baby may in fact
be extremely crappy!
I stand by my theory that we should all opt
for PUPPIES instead.
Hello hello everyone, Laci Green here for
DNews.
Our society tends to frame having a new baby
as something that's really exciting and wonderful...and
that's probably true for most.
But for some, it can bring an onslaught of
serious challenges.
Postpartum Depression, or PPD, is a type of
depression experienced mostly by new moms
that is very severe and can last several months
or years.
It goes beyond mood swings and anxiety - which
are common after-birth experiences.
PPD interferes with her ability to handle
everyday tasks by causing severe mood swings,
feelings of shame and inadequacy, difficulty
bonding with the infant, and perhaps even
thoughts about harming them.
Up to 1 in 5 women may experience PPD after
they've given birth.
The main cause is thought to be hormonal,
brought on by the fact that estrogen and progesterone
rapidly drop after childbirth.
But, it's not all physical.
It can also be brought on by the stress of
a new baby, lifestyle changes, a lack of support,
sleep deprivation--which may be at the heart
of a new study published in the journal Pediatrics
examining PPD in fathers.
The study looked at over 10,000 young fathers
for about 20 years and found that between
5 and 10% of them experienced clinical depression
in their first 5 years of being a dad.
This was only true for guys who became dads
in their 20s who lived with their children.
The scientists don't know what's causing the
PPD in fathers, but since there are no physical
changes, it's likely brought on by the lifestyle
changes that come with a new baby.
They noted that the transition to fatherhood
can be a challenging one -- especially when
you're young; you know, you might not have
a stable job or have married life itself fully
worked out yet.
The mental health status of parents is obviously
really important, not just because their quality
of life is at stake, but the baby's as well.
The first few months after an infant is born
is when parent-infant attachment happens.
It's the basis for the baby's relationship
with their caregivers as well as the outside
world.
Studies have found that mothers with PPD have
a harder time being that mediator.
Her personal challenges can cause a baby to
develop a more fearful and suspicious disposition
toward life and other people in the future.
A mother with PPD has also been linked to
behavioral problems in children.
Scientists are now examining how the infant's
attachment to the FATHER plays a role when
the father is afflicted with PPD.
So heyyyyy, pretty grim stuff.
But - it's a reality for a lot of people,
and fortunately, there are many therapeutic
and prescription treatments available to help
parents cope so they can feel like themselves
again and get on with their lives.
YAAAAY THANKS SCIENCE FOR HELPING PEOPLE.
And thank YOU for watching, we'll see you
next time with more DNews updates!